you are three-eyed Raven no I didn't
have time to learn I can't control
anything was there to control for the
night King comes
one way or another he will find his way
to the will of men when he does you will
be there waiting for him and you will be
ready welcome back for another character
breakdown video I am here with my good
friend gray area and today we are gonna
talk about bran Stark
in my opinion he is one of the hardest
characters to predict for because I feel
like his story can go in so many
different directions but we're gonna do
our best
alright gray when season 8 begins and we
see bran stark again for the first time
after he just witnessed the wall come
crashing down what do you think he does
first first I think he falls out of his
wheelchair no no I really think he's
gonna be scared and he's gonna want to
tell everyone like this is happening the
night king has crossed the wall I feel
like he might send Ravens to everyone
like send everybody than they have I
can't wait to see Daenerys his reaction
when she sees the night King pulled that
damn dragon out of that lake oh my gosh
yeah cuz she doesn't even know oh man
none of them know they assumed that
dragon just went underwater do you think
brain's gonna tell them or are they
gonna see it I'm kind of thinking when
John arrives at white Harbor word might
already be there that the night that the
wall fell when the night Kings coming
and I'm hoping that kind of speeds john
up to get his ass up north quick because
john was on the boat still when the Wall
fell so by the time John gets to white
Harbor news might already be spread
throughout the realm that like it it's
gonna be crazy like I'm real interested
to see what brands part to play is in
this brand can warg Ravens right yeah so
brand could possibly carry something to
John while he's still on the ship like
you got to get here now next
and they could just jump up drag on the
Dragons if they're nearby yeah that's a
very good point brain could have uh you
know the may still write a note stick it
in that raven and brain could fly the
raven to john at top speed and get word
to john fast within a day yeah yeah and
they're a lot faster his brain gonna
have time to even talk to John about his
true parents when John's gonna be busy
trying to stop the night king from you
know tearing down one or foul I don't
think so
when do you think that plays out I think
that happens near the end of the season
like first of all I I don't think John
dies so I think John finds out Harry
after so I think there's this there's
this battle once that's taken care of
bran might set straight John with his
parentage the only way I could see bran
telling John about his parentage is if
he needs to know who he is in order to
defeat those the night kids if he is
this the prince that was promised
because in my opinion John is Ice and
Fire Daenerys is just fire John is ice
and fire and I feel like the visions
that bran was shown by the three-eyed
Raven the that seemed to be most
important were to hold the door thing
John's parentage and the creation of the
White Walkers so we know the hold the
door thing was important because that's
how Brandis cape the cave and we know
the night king creation was important
because we needed to know what they were
and who they are and all that and who
created them but why did we need to know
who John's parentage why did bran need
to know that
yeah and you know it has to be important
because you know the main part of this
story is built on who John is and who
his parents were you know it is the Song
of Ice and Fire and it's one of the
biggest revelations so it's got to be
important to the end and that was what
bran was show like that was brand
Michelle met and he needed to see that I
remember like they didn't let him see it
right away
yeah yeah he held on back and he had to
go back and see it because he was like I
need to see everything the three-eyed
Raven said that's enough for today and
brain wanted to follow him and he said
no you know that's enough yeah who John
is is important so he may learn that
straight away that's gonna [ __ ] him up
yeah that's why I wanted to like
initially asked that because does he
want to tell John that right away when
the army of the Dead are coming like
does he want to hit the head John what
that big news when he knows he needs to
stop the night king first like that's a
big thing to learn when your mind needs
to be focused on stopping these guys
first
yeah bran might tell him in a way where
it was like they knew you had to be born
so they gave their lives like Liana and
Rhaegar so and they knew the risk and
Ned Stark your father
father cuz that still his dad like I
don't think anybody can take that away
from Jon yeah he raised him to be the
man he is so Ned knew what what you were
he he raised you as his own he raised
you how as a north man you're a north
man you're a stark he's gonna hate John
with that same line that John hit Theon
wit when John's healthy on you're a
Greyjoy
yeah he's gonna say you're a Targaryen
yeah that was definitely foreshadowing
John coming to terms with that about him
himself exactly because John right now
thinks that Rhaegar kidnapped his aunt
Lyanna and killed her when technically
they were in love they got married
you're not a best
you're not any of that and bran has to
reveal all that and and Sam's gonna have
to help as well do you think like after
he gets word out about the night king
bringing down the wall and coming
further south do you think bran will
continue to track the night king by
using birds so he can kind of let
everybody know where he's at at all
times yeah I do I do think that bran is
gonna and he could also use the trees if
you look at the opener of season seven
it looks like bran is warmed into one of
those White's the giant it looks like it
could be just cut like that but it
really looks like bran is warg into the
eye of one of those Giants holy [ __ ] did
you see that did you look at that I
never considered that but now that you
say that the camera does go right into
the Giants eye then it shows brand
coming out of that vision and we don't
see any Ravens around I don't know
anymore evens around I never considered
that but now that you say that huh that
would be crazy
[Music]
[Music]
yes so if bran can work a white he
couldn't couldn't [ __ ] you asleep II
with the army now I may have just been
cut like that because the next time we
see the night King on the March he's in
Ravens and he's not you know he's not
worked into a white at that point yeah
and if you could warg into a white why
wouldn't you just do that every time
definitely but that would be really cool
though yeah it would be really cool and
bran is like related to like a lot of
abominations like he he wargs into
humans even though that's an abomination
he eats humans even though that's an
abomination so I would think that
working the dead would be an abomination
as well uh-huh he's kind of he does all
those things that are forbidden that
you're not supposed to do he does him
staying on that same topic do you think
Brian will work anything in the future
to help during the war see I'm not sure
let me tell you let me explain this real
quick so he's the three-eyed Raven now
so I don't know what his actual
abilities are like does he still work
into things I think mainly he Ward's
into crows Ravens that's what he works
into your Ravens so I would think like
maybe he could do some scouting stuff
maybe he could do like the Ravens were
helpful I think to Sam and to cold hands
and the books but to Sam on the show
when they killed the white Walker I
think all those ravens that were there
at that time were Bloodraven related so
that's I feel like he has a part to play
I don't know what it is but when he when
benjin sends him back across the wall
benjin says the night king is coming and
you will be waiting for him so it's it's
definitely that to me the hero of the
story or the brand has a really big part
to play
yeah and that's actually one of my notes
I have written down
I literally have written here benjin
said he would be ready how well I mean
that's like a big line like yeah I mean
and that's that has to do at the end
game you know that what benjin said like
benjin knew and bran doesn't know yet
so it must be brand there's something
that brand still needs to learn that's
gonna get him ready and then when brain
is ready that's how he's gonna be able
to stop the night King but you know then
the million-dollar question is how will
he be ready or what will he learn that
will get him ready yeah and that's that
is the million-dollar question and I
don't think we have enough information
to really know that right now but I
could I can speculate that I think
brands major major role is it's like a
messenger role because that's what
Ravens are Ravens are messengers yeah
three-eyed Raven so his role is to tell
someone else what they need to do or
information yeah it doesn't seem like a
heroic thing but if you think about it
like Sam goes to the Citadel and he
finds information on how to kill the
White Walkers or what to do like when
when Sam sent John the raven like all
this dragon glasses at Dragonstone when
he send that to john like let's just say
that that dragon glass it becomes the
thing that stops the knight King from
advancing at all then Sam would be
looked at as the hero
so if brand telling John you know this
is what you need to do this is what was
done before you this is what was done
for you to do this this is what you have
to do that would mean that bran is the
is the actual Orchestrator of whatever
happens the information Sam finds out
and the information bran finds out is
just as important as what John is going
to do on the
battlefield and exactly yeah and I think
when it comes to a brand the information
he needs to learn to be ready for the
night King like benjin said I think Sam
is gonna play a role in that with
helping brand find and understand what
it is he needs to basically go back and
see that's gonna help them because we
know Gilley was looking at a book called
the long night and Sam was definitely
focusing on that book that was locked up
in his Citadel that had the phases of
the Moon and stuff like that in it yep
basically like we've seen with Sam and
bran finding out about John's parents I
think those two are gonna work together
and find out that big information with
how to stop the others or at least
better understand them or find out what
they want something big that has to do
with them and I actually saw a headline
today somebody was interviewing John
Bradley who is the guy that plays Sam he
basically hinted that those two are
gonna keep working together in season a
what do you think about that grey like
do you think those two will continue to
work together and they're gonna find
something for John I agree with that
100% I I don't remember who said it I
wish I remember who said it so I you
know give some more information on this
but I was I don't know if I was
listening to a podcast or something but
I think it was it was someone close to
the show or something like that I can't
remember the exact details but they were
saying that brand his abilities are like
a Google search like he has to be fed
information in order for him to learn
like okay so like Sam did he said well
it said that Rhaegar and Lyanna were
married in a secret ceremony and Dorne
so he was able to go right to that
location so if Sam has a book that says
well it says there was a long night at
this this date and this is when they
were defeated uh-huh
to that specific time and like he's
being fed a question like Google brain
can access anything in the past he just
needs to know where to look and say
Sam's gonna be that guy to find that
thing and along either the long night
book Gilly was looking at or something
he took from the Citadel and that's how
brain's gonna know exactly where to look
III agree a hundred percent so basically
staying on that same thing what do you
think he could possibly go back and see
that would help them today
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]